as liberal elites from around the world
slap each other on the back at the first
world economic forum since the covid
lockdowns a new pandemic is on the move
just in time
this time it's not a bat virus but a
monkey virus the world health
organization has now confirmed 80 cases
of monkey pox with outbreaks in 11
countries and the wh has further noted
that the outbreaks are unusual because
they're occurring in countries in which
the virus is not endemic
monkey pox can kill up to 10 percent of
people who catch it according to the cdc
and it's already here in the united
states there is at least one confirmed
case in massachusetts and another
possible case in new york
the good news is that some scientists
are warning people not to worry they say
that this is not a particularly virulent
form of the virus it does not transmit
easily it's no big deal of course the
public health establishment doesn't have
any credibility anymore so that's
unfortunate
but i'm not worrying i'm not worrying
i refuse to worry
maybe
this strange spread of a strange virus
is perfectly natural and accidental
maybe
maybe the illuminati cooked it up in a
lab at davos
maybe
i don't really care either way i don't
care i don't care if the libs start
dumping vats of anthrax on our heads out
of helicopters
all i know is i am not putting that
stupid mask back on
in a way
i actually sort of want them to lock
down again this could could be a great
opportunity right now while they are all
together in davos i think that we should
have an immediate lockdown and that way
all the sneering liberal globalist
backslapping hacks can continue to enjoy
each other's company forever
the rest of us can live our own lives
lock down davos and the rest of us might
finally be free again i'm michael
knowles this is the michael knoll show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment friday is from cool papa j magic
how many times has this guy been the
favorite comment that's wild he says lal
when the government says to freak out
you're probably fine when the government
says everything's great that's when
you've got to worry that is absolutely
true now one thing you don't need to
worry about is fixing your car because
of rock auto right now go to
rockauto.com enter knowles in their
headachy hero betis box so they know
that we sent you chances are over the
last year or so the value of your car
has gone up considerably this is in
large part due to inflation but what it
really means is you got to take care of
that car okay or truck or whatever
you're driving rockauto.com is the place
to do it you can pick brakes that match
how you use your vehicle whether that's
for towing racing or just commuting to
work when it comes to my car it's all
three at the same time you can get
suspension exhaust air conditioning
other kits that provide all the parts
you need for successful repair you will
not get halfway through replacing a belt
and discover you need another tensioner
pulley i hate that that's that's that's
my least favorite part about fixing up
my car i really love these guys they
have the absolute best prices they are
the
family-run business that's been serving
customers online for 20 years they've
been with this show from the very
beginning they'll help you save twenty
percent thirty percent fifty percent
easy to navigate website go to
rockauto.com right now for your audio
parts write knowles canon wles in their
headachy hereby box so they know that we
sent you
i am not a conspiracy theorist on the
world economic forum probably i should
be because the
difference between a conspiracy theory
and the truth as we know is about six to
nine months a conspiracy theory is just
a premature truth but i'm not a
conspiracy theorist on the world
economic forum i just don't like it
you don't need to believe that the world
economic forum is a secret cabal of
illuminati freemason jewish space aliens
to recognize that there is something
wrong with globalist elites politicians
corporate leaders from around the world
meeting up in this
not governmental just kind of weird
thing this thing that's not bound by
rules of politics or state they all meet
up and they all decide how they're going
to run our lives all around the world
and then these technocrats come back and
totally ignore the desires of
their constituents and totally ignore
the traditions and sometimes the laws of
the countries that they run and they
just they go because they're such
geniuses and they cook up the next 10
years in davos and then they come back
and try to force it down our throats
that's unfortunate and it's unfortunate
because not not because these people are
elite there are always going to be
elites not because world leaders are
talking to one another that's always
going to happen too
the problem is that these world leaders
these elites are idiots they're the
things that they cook up are so
obviously bad they're cartoonishly
villainous sometimes the ceo of pfizer
was speaking at the world economic forum
and this is another another conspiracy
theory that i guess is coming true
you remember a couple of years ago not
even maybe a year ago when
the elites were talking about the
various therapeutics and vaccines for
kovid people worried the kooky crazy
conspiracy theorists worried that
they're going to put a microchip in some
of these medicines
and that's going to send out an internet
signal maybe that was the wildest
conspiracy theory you're going to take a
drug and then there's going to be
internet coming through you and they're
going to track you and communicate with
you and everyone said no that's insane
you're a wild crazy nut that would never
happen so now the ceo of pfizer is
describing that exact thing
it is a
basically biological
chip that it is in the tablet
and once you take the tablet
and dissolves into your stomach sends a
signal but you took the tablet
so imagine the applications of that
compliance
the insurance companies to know that the
medicines that patients should take they
do
take them
it is uh fascinating what happens in in
this field
imagine what this means for compliance
that's what he says
like a james bond villain
this davos conference this world
economic forum it is like something out
of james bond where you have specter
ultrasound yeah the margin then you give
them the little computer chip with the
with the internet in the chip and then
it tells you everything that they do and
if they do not comply we will make them
comply we are the corporate leaders of
the world that davos
it's like he should be petting a little
white cat while he describes this
this is a terrible idea and you can see
it from his perspective
i i don't want to
straw man these these guys arguments
from their perspective they are the
smartest most virtuous wisest people in
the world and they meet up once a year
except for covet they had to take a
couple years off but they meet up once a
year and they decide how to improve
humanity and sometimes humanity has to
be dragged kicking and screaming into
into their improvement and sometimes
you've got to make them comply and so
now we've got all this wonderful
technology that will report if they're
not doing exactly what the elites want
them to do and if they don't then the
elites are going to come down and force
compliance
the issue is not
that there are elites the issue is not
that there are transnational elites the
issue is that these elites are idiots
first of all and they're
they're vicious they're vicious people
they're not virtuous people
they have no respect for anything they
are
they are just
secular
leftist people
who
have no respect for tradition no respect
for subsidiarity no respect for the law
no respect for anything other than their
own fettered reason which is going to
recreate the world and make it all so
wonderful even though every time they
they try one of these campaigns it all
turns to pot now speaking of the good
transnational elites there is really
really good news
coming out of the episcopacy coming out
of the catholic hierarchy there isn't a
lot of good news these days
that comes out of
the catholic hierarchy very often you
will see bishops
or even the pope say things that seem so
contradictory to the faith or do things
that are contradictory to tradition or
the faith but
we got a good one we got a good one
right at the end of last week
archbishop cora de leone who is the
archbishop of san francisco
has officially barred nancy pelosi from
holy communion
that we've got the letter here from
archbishop bishop core de leone saying
that nancy pelosi
is
advocating for abortion this is
a grave
problem
and this is creating scandal and she is
she is imperiling her own soul and and
he's tried to deal with her personally
he's tried to speak to her personally he
doesn't hear back and so he says i am
hereby notifying you that you are not to
present yourself for holy communion and
should you do so you are not to be
admitted to holy communion until such
time as you publicly repudiate your
advocacy for the legitimacy of abortion
and confess and receive absolution of
this grave sin in the sacrament of
penance please know that i stand ready
to continue our conversation at any time
and will continue to offer up prayer and
fasting for you now for people who do
not know
exactly what all of this means which
includes non-catholics certainly but a
lot of catholics too don't quite
understand what this means
according to the catholic faith it is
the bishop's obligation to do this this
is not just a punishment
to to punish nancy pelosi for her
supportive abortion
this is not just some arbitrary caprice
of the archbishop because he doesn't
like abortion but other bishops do like
abortion
it is
the obligation it is an act of mercy of
the bishop here to prevent nancy pelosi
from receiving communion because the
catholic church believes that if you
receive communion when you are not in a
state of grace if you receive communion
if you are in a state of grave mortal
sin you are eating your own damnation
you are you are further sinning by doing
that and so the shepherd leading his
flock has a responsibility and an
obligation to say no do not do this go
to penance
because this issue that we're talking
about here life this issue of abortion
is a non-negotiable issue there there is
not
any such thing as catholics for choice
or catholics for abortion right that's
not possible it is just ontologically
not possible the catholic church is
entirely opposed to abortion the
catholic church cannot change its
position on abortion it is not if a pope
came in one day and said we're for
abortion now he would not be able to do
that that is not a possible thing and so
it is
it is in the interest of nancy pelosi
and her immortal soul and certainly the
rest of the people who she is leading
astray through her scandal it is in
their best interest it is for their own
good that archbishop cordeliani is
saying you cannot receive holy communion
until you
until you
repent until you go to confession
confess your sins receive absolution
then you can do it again this is also
one such welcome courage finally we're
seeing courage from from
some bishops there are some good bishops
but a lot of bishops have been showing a
lot of cowardice here so now the
question is
what about joe biden
what about the other
so-called
catholic politicians who tout their
catholicism but then contradict the
teachings of the church will the other
bishops stand up and do what's right i
certainly hope so when you want to reach
people there are a lot of ways to reach
people one of the most direct ways is
through podium right now go to
podium.com knowles from supply chain
issues to increased demand on top of
everything else that business owners
have to manage the businesses who are
thriving right now are the ones who are
forward thinking podium helps your small
business stay ahead of the curve with
modern messaging tools that make it easy
for your customers to connect with your
business i absolutely love these guys
they're great for any kind of business
from health care providers to plumbers
they got over a hundred thousand
businesses that are texting their
customers through podium one car dealer
just sold a 50 000 truck in four text
messages that's all it took a jeweler
sold a five thousand dollar ring and
coordinated curbside pickup all through
text a dentist sent out payment requests
through texts received seventy percent
of their outstanding collections in just
two weeks with podiums all in one inbox
you can do even more than just chat you
get more online reviews by sending an
easy to use link collect payments fast
from anywhere send marketing campaigns
that actually get a response all by text
see how podium can grow your business
watch a demo today at podium.com knowles
that is podium.com knowles podium let's
grow
the libs are
furious that a catholic bishop is doing
his job
with regard to nancy pelosi keeping her
from receiving holy communion that is
the bishop's job it's his obligation if
the bishop doesn't do that he's going to
have to answer for that someday because
he will be neglecting his job and
allowing his flock to go astray and lead
one another astray the libs are furious
that the bishop is doing this
aoc
has has just suggested that this is a
not just cor de leone not just the
pelosi issue but the outlawing of
abortion generally is a grave threat to
religious freedom
people who say oh but you're you know
you're
you're harming a life i believe this is
life well some religions don't
so how about that
our jewish brothers and sisters they are
able to have an abortion according to
their faith you know
there are so many faiths
that do not have the same definition of
life as
fundamentalist christians
and so
we how what about their rights what
about their right to exercise their
faith
it's ridiculous
and it is it's
it is theocratic it's authoritarian
it is wrong
it's ridiculous it's theocratic it's
wrong what what aoc has said
as in terms of factual statements is
wrong the idea that judaism just totally
permits abortion is completely made up
it's nonsense
the jewish view of abortion is slightly
different than the christian view of
abortion that's true
but her idea here that it's part of the
jewish faith to commit abortions is just
ridiculous there was a
a sign that someone was holding at a
pro-abortion rally that said abortion is
a jewish value i thought whoa cool with
the anti-semitism here folks all right
that's what are you talking about
abortion is a jewish value
that's that is a smear of the jewish
people first of all it's not true
and second of all second of all
you do not have a right
to do whatever you want
because you say your religion tells you
to
some religions
aoc's comments about judaism
nonsense her comments about christianity
notice she says only fundamentalist
christians oppose abortion that's not
true christians oppose abortion
if you
support abortion you are violating your
christian faith and you call yourself a
christian you are violating the faith
you are speaking in a way that is
heterodox and heretical and you need to
be corrected but let's go beyond
christianity and judaism some religions
practice virgin sacrifice
some religions practice ritual
cannibalism
many of the
religions of the americas before the
european christians got here practiced
sacrifice of virgins practiced ritual
cannibalism and so
is that is it a violation of religious
liberty to say now in the united states
in the year of our lord 2022 you are not
allowed to slaughter babies and eat them
is that a violation you're not allowed
to slaughter virgins on altars is that a
violation of religious liberty
in a way it is
in a way to give aoc her due yes you are
telling certain religious groups that
you're not allowed to do things
religious liberties such as it is is
limited
it doesn't mean that you can just do
whatever you want to do there are guard
rails there are standards okay
the whole concept of religious liberty
arises in a very specific
religious context namely out of
protestant christianity
so that's the context here that those
are the guard rails when religious
liberty was first being proposed by the
liberal thinkers
no one ever had any thought that you
could no one had any thought that we
would tolerate atheists let alone people
committing human sacrifice let alone
people just doing whatever they want in
the name of religious liberty no that's
not what it means that's not what the
term means philosophically that's not
what the term means historically it's
just nonsense to quote aoc it's
ridiculous
it's totally ridiculous
speaking of hispanics and politics
the support among hispanics for joe
biden
is
collapsing
turns out most hispanics and politics
are not like aoc turns out most
hispanics in american politics are
normal people and they are not wild-eyed
leftist ideologues and
their support for joe biden is
collapsing according to a quinnipiac
poll that was conducted in may 2021 so
just about a year ago
biden's approval rating among hispanics
was at 55 percent
according to the 2020 polls after the
election so you know take it with a
grain of salt
uh joe biden won 59 of the hispanic vote
in 2020. what do you think his numbers
among hispanics are at right now
55 59 it's down to 26
26
just about a quarter of hispanics
support joe biden right now
just 27 support biden's economic
policies
this is lower than the national average
national average of people who support
biden's economic policies 32
hispanics five points lower hispanics
have also ranked inflation as the most
pressing issue concerning them
the democrats need hispanics
if we have free and fair elections i
hope that we do and the democrats do not
win the hispanics
they are almost certainly completely
screwed in the midterm elections and in
2024.
why what has caused this cratering of
hispanic support well in part it's
because the democrats have failed on
everything it's because joe biden's
presidency has been an unmitigated
disaster we are too we are worse off on
every measure every state in the union
right now has gas above four dollars a
gallon in some places it's way higher
foreign policy has gone to hell we now
have the first major war in europe since
world war ii immigration is awful and
the democrats mistakenly believe that
legal hispanics in america really like
open borders and illegal immigration
polls show that is not the case
hispanics who are in america legally
don't generally like illegal immigration
all that much what about the economy
obviously the economy record high
inflation
terrible economic indicators here it's
just a bad situation
for the democrats and so what are they
doing to turn the ship of state around
here's kamala harris's answer this
afternoon we had many of us the
administrator and
a number of us the opportunity to be
inside of an electric school bus and it
was fantastic the press actually wrote
on an electric school bus just so you
know so i think they got the real inside
feeling for what this means right
and so what we all experienced is
on an electric school bus on an electric
bus no exhaust
no diesel smell can you believe that
guys
we took this electric bus
and it was like it was kind of quiet it
was like
yeah and you remember and then you think
you're like are you gonna pull up to a
gas station but you don't you don't it
just
it's isn't that amazing
what lady what are you talking about
what
how are you the vice president
well
all right we don't need to get into that
lady how did you make it this far in
politics people want to know while we
have record high energy costs we have a
major war going on that's going to throw
energy costs even higher the democrats
are prattling on about how much better
the electric buses smell meanwhile
they're cancelling new oil and gas
leases in alaska and elsewhere meanwhile
they're cancelling oil pipelines
saying ha ha record high energy prices
yeah it's going to get a lot higher but
vroom vroom
wow you ever you ever ride on one of
those fun you ever hear of a tesla oh no
they hate tesla now actually because
elon's gonna buy twitter but they're
they're just they are talking
about issues they are speaking to things
that are so totally removed from
people's ordinary experience of life and
actual cares and reality
that unless they rig every single ballot
box in this car i don't see
how the midterm elections could be
anything but a disaster for them
unless they unless they rigged the
ballot boxes unless they lock us all
down again for monkey pox or something
i don't because they are so incredibly
removed
from the cares of ordinary americans
speaking of school buses
speaking of schools
you know
the the libs are looking at the polls
and they're seeing that
peddling radical sexual theories in
schools doesn't play very well
not only does it not play well in
conservative states it doesn't play well
in liberal states either it turns out
that a whole slow widespread of voters
not just white voters but black and
hispanic not just republicans but
democrats and liberals too they don't
like it when you try to transgender
their little kids they think that's
weird and so the democrats first have
denied that it's happening
but we know it's happening we've seen it
in virginia and we've seen it in florida
and you've seen the voters come out
and elect republicans in those kind of
places in large part because of these
issues
they see how badly this polls
and they try to deny that it's happening
and they say no we aren't teaching weird
sex stuff to kids and it's really good
that we are there's a new video out
thanks to chris ruffo who's done a great
job on this issue in particular
it shows that the matzoni center
has just hosted a big conference
on on how important it is to transgender
the kids in schools the matzoni center
has
sex programs full-time staff that teach
sex programs in philadelphia public
schools all the way up to grade 12 all
the way down to kindergarten now when
you're concerned about what's going to
happen with your kids you got to check
out epic will right now go to
epicwill.com
promo code knowles okay if you
god forbid something happened to you
right now what would happen to your
stuff what would happen to your property
what would happen to your kids
would would your kids be raised in
accordance with what you believe the way
that you well if you don't have a will
right now you don't really have a say in
any of that okay
let that sink in
let that sink in no say in not just the
future of your stuff the future your
business is the future of your kids if
you're single you think you don't need a
will you could not possibly be more
wrong a will allows you to establish
advanced directive and medical power of
attorney you really want to leave the
burden of deciding huh do i do i keep
this person on life support do i take
them off life support you want to leave
that to one of your friends or family
members you don't want to communicate
what you really want come on get it done
do the responsible thing if you haven't
made one yet you're not alone i just
finished my own wheel a couple of weeks
ago we're making it easy for you at
epicwill.com when you use promo code
knowles you can go it takes a very short
amount of time you get all of your
affairs in order they are partnering
with us at the daily wire taking care of
us protecting our staff and families let
them protect yours epicwhell.com promo
code knowles secure your future in as
little as five minutes with a complete
package starting at 119 bucks when you
use promo code knowles you'll save 10
epic will.com the most important five
minutes you will spend today
there is something
so satisfying in building a case so
tight that there's almost nothing the
opposition can say that will make any
difference that's what we have done
in our daily wire original documentary
choosing death where we look
at the heinous court decision of roe v
wade we take a wrecking ball to the four
fallacies that the abortion industry is
built on right now candace owens is
doing the same with black lives matter
in the new daily wire documentary the
greatest lie ever told george floyd and
the rise of blm you've seen how candace
has been relentlessly calling out these
media driven lies around racial justice
for the last two years when you set out
to make a documentary
look you don't know exactly where the
facts will take you as it turns out
candace has uncovered kryptonite all
right we are going to take some more
time putting this film together before
we bring it to light it's amazing i've
i've kind of seen behind the scenes how
this movie has come together it is
incredible as candace likes to say
sunshine is the best disinfectant the
greatest lie ever told george floyd in
the rise of blm is going to be
incredible trust me it will be well
worth the wait we'll be right back with
a lot more
welcome back to the show
the matzoni center
promotes transgenderism and weird sex
stuff to kids in philadelphia schools
grades k through 12.
last year they secured five million
dollars in government contracts here is
uh just a little taste of the sort of
lesson that you would receive at a
matzoni center class or conference
i am rachel simon i use she her pronouns
i am a psychotherapist educator
consultant and author
i run my private practice here in
philadelphia and i am the author of the
everybody book which is a
an lgbtq inclusive
um sex ed resource for seven to twelve
year olds and i love that you said that
this this talk specifically was geared
towards teens but you're so right that
sexuality education starts
the minute you're born i mean we have
we're born with bodies these bodies are
cool we want to touch our bodies we're
learning about um privacy and you know
being
sexual in public from a very early age
homophobic and transphobic ideas from
parents can absolutely be a problem
inescapable judgment
yeah bigoted misinformed parents who
have no idea how to talk about gay sex
they're biased if they are religious it
can be very difficult to get into the
conversation with them
it can be really difficult if those
parents aren't radical sexual
revolutionaries like i am who want to
not only
promote
all sorts of unusual sexual desires and
behaviors among people but also trans
your five-year-olds yeah it can be
really hard and that's why it's so
important that we go into the schools
with government money by the way with
five million dollars in government
contracts to go in there and teach your
kids
how absolutely terrible you are and and
to totally contradict every value you've
ever taught them and to make them like
me and obviously well-adjusted not total
psycho right right that's
that's what she's saying
they're not hiding it
this is not i'm not reading between the
lines she is telling you this she's
saying we hate it when parents
teach their kids traditional religious
values
you raise your kid christian
or jewish or muslim for that matter
we hate that that's bad
so what we do is we go in with with the
parents taxpayer money by the way we go
in to the schools and say yeah your
parents are bigoted they're they're
misogynistic they're they're awful
closed-minded
and don't believe what they say believe
what we say thank you parents by the way
for funding my salary uh yeah we we just
go we go into the schools
and we and we tell kids that they need
to embrace the rainbow
that's what's happening we knew it was
happening
then the libs deny that it's happening
then they tell us it's good that it's
happening but they still deny that it's
happening
and sometimes we need to see it with our
own eyes
there is no
live and let live here
conservatives first impulse very often
is i live and let live if you guys want
to do that that's fine but just don't
force it on me however you want to live
that's fine just don't make me do it
throw your hands in the air
there's no neutrality
there is no well you do you don't yuck
none of that
the kids are either going to learn
traditional sexual morality
or radical lgbtq lmnop trans the kids
sexual morality
they will not learn no sexual morality
that woman has a point
when she says that we start to have
questions about our sex not i'm not
saying
erotic questions i'm saying just what is
a boy what is a girl what do boys and
girls mean what is mommy and daddy they
start to have these questions very very
young
people do have questions about their
bodies at a young age and certainly as
they approach puberty they start to have
these questions more and
more and if we spend
eight hours of our day in school when
we're little kids then we're gonna learn
things there too we're gonna learn
things among other kids and with the and
we're gonna ask questions of our
teachers and it yes you are gonna learn
that stuff the question is what are you
going to learn what is going to be
taught
it's not even any longer going to be ask
your parents
ask your parents
was a substantive answer what that
answer means is your parents have the
right to inculcate in you a certain
sexual
tradition and understanding but now
that's being contradicted by the left
even even that is considered reactionary
now how do those parents are bigoted and
awful and misogynist they're going to
destroy their kids lives no we have a
responsibility to go into the schools
so what is it which one are we you have
to make a choice you it can't just be
well do whatever you want
what do you want your kids to be raised
by that psycho in that video or do you
want your kids to be raised in a
more traditional way
if the answer is the latter as i suspect
it is then we need to go in and wield
state power and defund the matsony
center and take away its five million
dollars in government contracts and fire
lunatics like that girl in the video and
fire teachers if they teach this kind of
stuff in the schools and pass laws
saying that you can't teach this kind of
stuff in the schools that's the only
thing you can do otherwise you are
giving over the whole culture and the
way your kids are raised to these
weirdos i think it was auron mcintyre i
i've quoted this viral tweet on my show
multiple times now which is
the party that wants to win is always
going to beat the party that just wants
to be left alone
that that is an eternal rule of politics
he's not the first guy to say it but his
version of it went viral on on the
internet
we need to want something we need to
want to win we need to have a
substantive vision of the country if not
if we just want to kind of be left alone
then that lady is the is the new mommy
that lady is raising your kids okay
you're seeing it teachers are not hiding
this they're bragging about this
here's a teacher just took to tiktok
we're seeing it thanks to our friends at
libs of tick tock who who said that
although there are laws now being passed
in the country to stop teachers from
inculcating radical sexual ideology in
their young kids her pride flag is the
most important thing in her classroom
i'm a teacher in a very conservative
state and so sometimes students ask me
why do i have that pride flag
and to me that's the most important part
of my classroom i'm not lgbtq i'm
totally straight married to a man
but i need my students to know that they
are safe and they are loved here without
making a big deal about it without
having like a big conversation
so by having
just that teeny little flag at the front
of my room
i can communicate to them that i support
them and that this is a safe place for
them where they can focus on learning
and that
means everything to me and if a student
has a problem with it then they can find
a different teacher
she's so nice isn't she she just wants
everyone to feel safe and loved do you
think christian students will feel safe
and loved when they see that flag that
flag which means you are wrong
that flag which means your views are not
legitimate that your views are evil and
bigoted
and need to be run out of the public
square do you think the christian how
about the jewish students do you think
the jewish students
the jewish students who take their
religion seriously do you think that
they feel safe and welcome when they see
that flag that flag which says you are
wrong and you are evil and your views
should be run out of town muslim
students do you think
muslim students take this stuff
real seriously do you there's not
there's not a whole lot of liberalism in
islam like there is in christianity and
judaism do you think that
or like they're i should say like there
can be in christianity in judaism
obviously the more orthodox christians
and jews do not have a lot of liberalism
in their in their religion do you think
the muslims feel safe and welcome when
the pride flag is there saying you are
you are wrong you are evil you are
bigoted your culture is disgusting
do you think that i don't think they do
no i give the teacher credit because
she's being honest
in that yes to her
and to so many of these revolutionaries
the pride flag is the most important
thing because
all human conflict ultimately is
theological
and
beyond reading writing and arithmetic
when we educate people we're teaching
them the most basic things the most
important things who we are what we are
what does it mean to live the good life
what are we aiming at what should we do
what is virtue so of course the flag
actually is the most important thing
more so than the whiteboard and the
abacus that's for sure
because it's getting to the very root of
education what is education for
now i don't think education should be
aimed at instilling pride in people i
think i think pride is a sin and the
queen of all sins and pride goes before
destruction and a haughty spirit before
a fall and i think that the sexual
pathologies that the the pride flag
represents are not particularly helpful
to people and i don't think it's very
helpful to tell seven-year-old boys that
they're actually little girls
i don't think that helps them she might
sincerely believe that that will help
them that might be her deeply held
religious view
and that contradicts the religious views
of the christians and the jews and the
muslims and you know what folks the aoc
version of religious liberty
where you just you should be able to do
whatever you want that's not that's an
incoherent answer
because you can't simultaneously teach
both you cannot simultaneously teach
boys are boys and girls are girls and
boys can be girls and girls can be boys
those are mutually exclusive
those are contradictory statements
you have to pick one
the christians the jews and the muslims
they believe the first one
the liberals and the secularists and the
leftists and the progressives they
believe the latter one
those are religious it's an actual
religious conflict it's not just
political or cultural and we've got to
pick and we in the political human
community have every right to pick and
we have every right to settle certain
religious questions
our declaration of independence says
that we hold these truths to be
self-evident that all men are created
equal and endowed by their creator with
certain unalienable rights that is a
religious
statement
about god that is the predicate for our
country
if you
if you do not believe in that
then you do not have a much of a place
in america that is a limit to the
religious liberty of america
as so many people have pointed out
religious liberty in america does not
mean freedom from religion it might mean
freedom of religion but it doesn't mean
freedom from religion
and religious liberty is not even the
point of the first amendment by the way
when we talk about the establishment
clause of the first amendment
that doesn't mean that there's absolute
total religious liberty this is one of
the most misunderstood clauses of the
entire constitution the reason that the
framers of the constitution did not
establish a church at the national level
was in large part because the states
already had established churches they
already had certain states most mostly
were episcopalian but there were other
establishments as well that persisted
for decades after the constitution
so yeah that's what religious freedom
really means we need to put limits here
we need to use the law to do it we need
to tell that weirdo teacher hey take
that flag down or get out of the
classroom oh that's the most important
thing in your classroom okay well then
find another job because this job ain't
for you speaking of finding other jobs
really great news coming out of
hollywood an actor is suing his talent
agency for racial discrimination
this actress tyler fisher happens to be
in a daily wire movie terror on the
prairie tyler says i'm currently suing a
talent manager who told me they won't
work with me because i'm a white man
they just asked how much money i want to
settle out of court for update i will
not settle i will take this all away
even if i don't get a dime this
justified racism needs to end absolutely
right it is very important to end
affirmative action they call it
affirmative action it just means racial
discrimination against whites and in
some cases asians that's what
affirmative action is and it's wrong
and it's politically disastrous and we
need to get rid of it there's no
argument for it
the old argument for affirmative action
was that
certain groups have been historically
really just one group of black people
have been historically discriminated
against by the law in the united states
and so to try to fix that situation to
correct that we're going to go in and
give them special advantages and
discriminate against white people and
then that'll kind of level things out
and
everyone will be happy and kumbaya right
that was the idea and i kind of get the
idea behind it
it has not achieved its purpose
the purpose of affirmative action was to
help black people improve their position
in american society and to integrate the
society it has achieved neither of those
things
in some cases it's had the opposite
effect there was a major study about
this from ucla law professor richard
sander years ago probably over 15 years
ago at this point that
published in the stanford law review
looked at the effects of affirmative
action and showed that affirmative
action has actually harmed
the position of black people in society
professionally
one of the explanations for this was
mismatch theory that when you put
certain when you give certain students
an unfair advantage and you put them
into
either colleges or other institutions in
which they are not
well matched they're actually going to
fail at a much higher rate than if they
were in other institutions to which they
were better matched antonin scalia got
in a lot of trouble for raising this
possibility and they called him a racist
as they always do but it's a totally
legit
scenario and it doesn't help anyone
especially not black people to deny that
you look at the position of black people
in american society in 1965
before affirmative action 24 of black
babies were born out of wedlock today
it's upwards of three quarters of black
infants born out of wedlock if the point
of affirmative action was
racial integration and harmony in the
u.s
where is racial integration and harmony
today we're at new lows we've just had
race riots for for eight months in the
year 2020 and we've got the blm movement
shaking down corporations everywhere
racial relations seem to be at all new
lows
so if that hasn't worked and if the end
of the policy is unjust in and of itself
it's time to get rid of it great great
stuff for tyler fisher take it on man do
not stop fighting this fight it's it's
important not just for white people not
just for men it's important not just for
asians it's important for everybody
speaking of
weird
racial and sexual ideologies
there is some really weird sex stuff
going on i every day i think that we've
hit the bottom of the slippery slope and
we can't get into any weirder sex stuff
and we and then we do we do every time
this is called have you heard of this
this is called
nullification surgery
gender nullification surgery
this is being practiced
by licensed quacks
gender nullification surgery
while many patients might be interested
in transitioning into either a male or
female identity
there are plenty of individuals who feel
that their gender identity does not
quite conform in one direction or the
other
gender nullification surgery can enable
non-conforming patients to enjoy a
relatively smooth
genital area
it means they turn you into barbie means
they turn you into can they just get rid
of your genitals entirely not so that a
man can look more like a woman or a
woman look more like a man so that you
just look like nothing
so that you look completely
neutral
do we think people should be allowed to
do this i don't think so i think that
medical professionals have an obligation
first to do no harm and i think this is
harming them and they should not be
allowed to do this and when medical
professionals do this we should put them
in jail i think we should have laws
against this that prohibit that limit
the freedom of individuals the bodily
autonomy of individuals to chop
themselves up and make them look like a
barbie doll i think that's wrong harmful
to them
there's no good served by it as edmund
burke points out you do not have a right
to do things that are not reasonable and
not for your benefit
so no
no you don't get to do that
but this actually oddly enough
ties in with the big
liberal buzz phrase of last week this
ties in with the great replacement you
know the great replacement is this
phrase that the left is demagogued it
refers
politically speaking it refers to this
idea that the political forces are using
mass migration to change the electorate
of a population so that the
a certain party like the democrats for
instance will have a permanent majority
this is a crazy wild nuts conspiracy
theory except the democrats have told us
they're doing this for over 10 years now
and they they tell us that they're doing
it and then we repeat to them what
they've said and then they call us
racist awful conspiracy theorists for
repeating their very words back to them
so that's that's one stage of the great
replacement you're seeing this in europe
too uh victor orban the leader of
hungary
has accused the eu of doing this said
brussels is abusing its powers every
single day and trying to force bad and
foreign things upon us but
we're not going to give up our border
protection but then he went a little bit
deeper he said the west just does not
want to maintain itself let's not read
it around a beat around the bush certain
civilizations are able to reproduce the
west is not able to reproduce
and there are people who sense the
problem of declining demographics and
they want migration so he's saying it's
not it's not merely about the liberal
parties wanting to get more power and
they know the migrants are more likely
to vote for them so they push mass
migration this is also being promoted by
corporate leaders this is also being
promoted by technocrats this is also
being
being pushed by economists who realize
that if you've got declining birth rates
and you've got increasing entitlements
and you've got an aging population you
need more people to go in there to work
to pay for the entitlements you've got
to keep the economy afloat well the only
way to do that they say is through mass
migration that's a deeper kind of
cultural level here and then there there
is an even deeper level of it so for
anyone who's interested in reading the
theory of the great replacement i'm not
talking about
kooky
screeds on the internet or the ravings
of mad men and murderers but i'm talking
about the actual philosopher behind this
idea who i assure you know no one who
has ever committed violence in the name
of the great replacement has ever read
this guy even though he's the guy who
coined the term his name is uh uh
gosh what is it oh renault camus sorry i
was reading the uh the
author of this piece nathan pinkowski
minkowski who's a really great writer
compact magazine the man behind the
great replacement and this is about
renault camus
and he's this french guy and he says the
issue it's not just about
race it's not just about nationality
it's not just about people from the
third world wanting to get economic
advantage in the first world it's about
a whole ideology of replacism
the idea that
everything is just
replaceable
and
you see this is a long way of getting
back to the gender theory but you see it
especially with the gender theory it's
this idea that
america is not unique
france is not unique
italy is not unique they're just kind of
they're just states
and so you can if you replace all the
italians with the french
or
more likely if you replace all the
italians with people from the middle
east or africa you'll still have italy
because it'll still be the same place
you'll get totally different people but
it'll be the same place and of course
that's not true you can't replace all
the people of a culture and maintain
that culture you can't dr flood a
country with migrants who have their own
culture and then expect them instantly
to assimilate
especially when assimilation is being
discouraged by the elites but it goes
even deeper
the idea of replacism is that you can
replace men with women and women with
men it's the idea that that everyone is
different undifferentiated it's the idea
that
you you just plug in a new part we're
all
nothing makes us special nothing is deep
nothing binds us to the past nothing is
particular about a geographic area or a
tradition or none of you just replace
everything we're all guilty of that we
live in an age of disposable things we
don't make things anymore out of sturdy
materials we make them out of steel and
glass and plastic
plastic more than anything
and so it's all
replaceable
a women
women are replaceable we'll replace them
with men
babies are replaceable we'll replace
them with puppies
we won't
our our own civilization is replaceable
we'll replace them with people from
another civilization we won't even try
to assimilate them because culture's not
real religion's not real it's all just
but we know that that's not true
we're seeing that tension in our battles
right now
the battle between christianity and
secular leftism in the schools
we're seeing that in the battle the
fight over transgenderism the fight over
nationalism versus globalism
the the people the technocrat
self-descri self-appointed geniuses in
brussels
who are going to remake the world after
their own fancies that that ideology it
has nothing to do with
frankly it doesn't even have that much
to do with race it doesn't have anything
to do with mass murderers or crazy
theories about the illuminati and the
the freemasons and the jewish space
aliens or anything like that it has to
do with a basic fact of the way that we
all live right now we're living in a way
in which particularity is gone and and
that is that is pretty sad you see it
especially with gender i i like women i
think women make great women i don't
want to see women mutilating themselves
to pretend to be like men or vice versa
that that is the much deeper level of of
this whole discussion which of course
the mainstream media do not want us to
have because it will impede their agenda
i'm michael knowles this michael knowles
show see you tomorrow
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadofsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 22.
today on the ben shapiro show joe biden
says the united states will militarily
defend taiwan in case of chinese
invasion monkey pox freaks out the world
and stocks continue to edge into bear
market territory as the administration
desperately flails as today on the bench
bureau show give it a listen
you